der frühling 2021 wird anders sein als
der frühling vor einem jahr einen fünf
stufen plan gegen korona die lockerungen
kommen schrittweise mit eingebauter
notbremse mehr sicherheit durch
selbsttests ab samstag soll das erste
setzt im supermarkt zu kaufen geben
gleiches geld für gleiche arbeit die eu
will dass frauen genauso viel verdienen
wie ihre kollegen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
heute 19 uhr wie immer mit nachrichten
vom sport von und mit rudi cerne hallo
schon genannt nach vielen wochen der
einschränkungen wird wieder gelockert
stufenweise das haben kanzlerin und
ministerpräsidenten runde beschlossen
doch so wie die infektionszahlen wieder
stärker ansteigen greift eine notbremse
auch sonst bestimmt die korona situation
bahn überhaupt was gilt bei vielen der
präsentierten beschlüsse
das passe auf ein blatt papier sagen die
gipfelteilnehmer
trotzdem ist es kompliziert die
wichtigsten regeln fasst christoph
distel zusammen ein bisschen mehr
freunde und bekannte sehen das wird ab
montag gehen maximal zu fünf kinder wenn
alle aus zwei haushalten stammen auch in
die städte kommt wieder etwas mehr leben
buchhandlungen blumenläden und
gartenmärkte dürfen öffnen außerdem
kosmetikstudios und fahrschulen alle
weiteren lockerungen hängen von der
infektions lage in ihrer region ab
theoretisch dürfen ab montag auch schon
die einzelhändler auf machen genau wie
museen und galerien und zoos aber nur da
wo die inzidenz unter 100 liegt zwischen
50 und 100 muss man für einkauf oder
kultur einen termin buchen erst unter 50
wirtz leicht da gilt maske auf und nicht
so viele menschen auf einmal zwei wochen
muss die inzidenz regional dann stabil
bleiben für den nächsten schritt die
öffnung der restaurants im außenbereich
der theater und kinos alles wieder
relativ unkompliziert bei einer inzidenz
unter 50 darüber geht nichts ohne termin
buchung oder corona test wenn es gut
läuft folgen weitere lockerungen im
zwei-wochen-rhythmus auch im
freizeitsport von außen kontaktfrei bis
schließlich innen mit kontakt wenn es
schlecht läuft greift für all diese
regeln eine notbremse steigt irgendwo
die inzidenz nachhaltig über 100 geht es
zurück auf anfang auf die winter
einschränkungen wichtig damit alle
möglichst früh wissen ob sie selbst
ansteckend sind wird es für die meisten
von uns mindestens einen kostenlosen
schnell
das geben pro woche einplanen der auf
eine din a4 seite passen soll klingt
einfach und klar trifft das denn
tatsächlich zuschauer konnte bennati ich
würde sagen das trifft zum teil zu den
wenn man sich diese din a4 seite anguckt
dann kann man tatsächlich mit ein
bisschen ruhe ganz gut verstehen was
darauf steht aber in der realität sieht
es dann doch wieder anders aus denn in
deutschland startet ja nicht
flächendeckend von ein und demselben
wert dass es gestaffelt das ist auch
zeitlich gestaffelt und so werden wir
wahrscheinlich sehr bald in eine
situation kommen in der alle
bundesländer vielleicht sogar alle
regionen in unterschiedlichen öffnungs
phasen sind und das sorgt dann zwar für
mehr freiheit vor ort aber auch für mehr
verwirrung in der fläche fairerweise
muss man dazu sagen
dieser plan soll ja für die kommenden
wochen und monate und möglichst lange
halten und auch möglichst alle zufrieden
stellen und das geht wohl nur mit einem
gewissen maß an komplexität tank und
teller wir sprechen uns gleich nochmal
wollen aber erst noch einen blick auf
die nacht der entscheidung werfen
da waren die erwartungen hochgesteckt
entsprechend stark der druck auf die
bund und länder runde
und so hat es wieder ziemlich lange
gedauert bis man sich einig wurde und
kanzlerin merkel kurz vor mitternacht
vor die presse treten konnte dennoch
sind heute bei weitem nicht alle
zufrieden wie thomas reiter zeigt kurz
vor mitternacht nach über neun stunden
verhandlungen verkündet angela merkel
gestern abend ein wagnis lockerungen
trotz wieder steigender infektionszahlen
es sollen schritte der eröffnungs sein
und gleichzeitig schritte die uns in der
pandemie nicht zurückkaufen dürfen
es war ein hartes langes ringen am ende
bot sich merkel dem druck vieler länder
auf öffnungen unter der bedingung dass
es die notbremse gibt die rückkehr zum
schottern bei instanzen über 100 die
entscheidung zur eröffnung baut ganz
darauf dass tests und impfungen nun
schneller vorankommen als das virus
impfen und testen gibt und unterstützt
uns und ist eine einem wahnsinnigen
hilfe in der situation in der wir sind
aber wir werden auch weiter mit den
jetzt schon bekannt
regeln leben müssen eine taskforce zur
test strategie soll es nun geben
angeführt von gesundheits und
verkehrsministerium aber gibt es
überhaupt genug tests viele länder haben
zweifel geben so die opposition
jetzt soll eine eine task force gebildet
werden für die logistik der testungen
angeführt von jens spahn und andreas
scheuer
also da hat man fast den eindruck das
ist realsatire hier werden
offensichtlich die böcke zu gärtnern
gemacht auch bei den impfungen geht es
nur langsam voran
frühestens ende märz sollen hausärzte
impfen können
es bleibt ein echter kardinalfehler an
und dann ist schwere hypothek in der
gesamten kroner pandemie dass dieses
versäumnis besteht dass nur langsam
wieder aufzuholen ist der gebeutelte
einzelhandel kann zumindest auf kleine
öffnungen hoffen für die fdp sind die
schritte dennoch zu klein und zu zaghaft
schon heute wäre es möglich mit masken
und den entwickelten hygiene konzepten
zum beispiel im handel und in teilen der
gastronomie verantwortungsvoll zu öffnen
so viel wollten sie gestern nun doch
nicht wagen und haben es vertagt auf die
nächste konferenz in knapp drei wochen
soweit die stimmen aus der politik und
wie reagiert die wirtschaft was sagen
gastwirte und einzelhändler rinnen zu
den beschlüssen aus der nacht wir haben
uns umgehört
das ist nicht die große erleichterung
das ist die tür einen spalt auf mit dem
ständigen fragezeichen mit dem ständigen
damoklesschwert was passiert nun wenn es
hoch geht oder mit der ständigen
hoffnung was wann geht sie vielleicht
mal unter 50 das ist schon sehr sehr
nervenaufreibend wir sind absolut
frustriert wir sind eigentlich empört
darüber dass unsere branche überhaupt
nicht richtig zur kenntnis genommen wird
die gastronomie ist nicht mehr flexibel
ich glaube da das ist jetzt auch klar
geworden über die letzten monate fast
ein jahr jetzt wir können auch nicht
mehr flexibel sein weil wir nicht das
geld dazu herr rechnen tut sich jedes
stück das ich verkaufe ich bin ja froh
wenn wenn ich meinen kundinnen damit
eine freude machen kann
und auch die ware apfel kaufen kann
gemischtes echo
nochmal zuschlag unterleib energy nach
berlin wie schätzen sie das ergebnis
denn ein kommt die regierung damit raus
aus der defensive
dafür wird es wohl nicht reichen
ich denke eher im gegenteil jetzt steht
ja mit diesem plan schwarz auf weiß fest
wie viel mehr freiheit man gewinnen
könnte wenn man tatsächlich konsequent
und richtig testen und impfen würde und
vor diesem hintergrund treten jetzt die
versäumnisse die bei der test strategie
und auch bei der impfstrategie vorher
gemacht worden sind noch sehr viel
deutlicher zu tage
da werden jetzt die fragen lauter warum
hat man sich da nicht eher darum
gekümmert warum wurde bei der test
beschaffung wurden da so viele fehler
gemacht warum wird es jetzt eine test
strategie wirklich ausgearbeitet im
detail und warum werden es jetzt
strukturen aufgebaut also da ballt sich
doch eine ganze menge unmut wir haben es
in den oppositions tönen gerade gehört
und diese stimmen werden jetzt von tag
zu tag je länger man wartet dass es
richtig losgeht er lauter als leiser
die einordnung von schrack unterleib
energy vielen dank dafür nach berlin und
dann schauen wir an dieser stelle auf
die zahlen der virus krise das robert
koch institut meldet 11.900 zwölf neue
infektionen in 24 stunden 43 mehr als am
vergangenen donnerstag 359 weitere
todesfälle geben sie in verbindung mit
coop 19
die sieben tage incidents liegt
bundesweit bei 64,7 mehr tempo beim
impfen und ganz viel testen das sind die
grundlagen für die geplanten lockerungen
für den astra zeneca impfstoff gibt es
jetzt auch in deutschland grünes licht
für menschen die älter als 65 sind und
an den impfungen sollen sich spätestens
ab april auch die hausärzte beteiligen
kostenlose schnelltests für alle seien
ausreichend vorhanden versichert das
gesundheitsministerium und selbsttests
für zuhause sollen schon in den nächsten
tagen zu kaufen sein
dominik müller russ l
es ist deutlich angenehmer als bislang
beim selbsttest genügt ein abstrich aus
dem vorderen nasenbereich dann den
abstrich in das röhrchen mit der test
flüssigkeit nach einer minute ein paar
dieser tropfen auf den teststreifen das
ergebnis lässt sich nach einer
viertelstunde ablesen die sicherheiten
schwanken zwischen 690 und 99 prozent je
nach hersteller der zugelassene
präparate
man geht davon aus dass man drei bis
fünf stunden auf jeden fall sicher gehen
kann dass die viruslast entweder gar
nicht da ist oder so gering ist dass ich
jetzt keinen anstecken könnte ein
zeitfenster also um verwandte oder
freunde zu treffen zeigt der selbst test
dagegen corona an muss das schnellstens
professionell überprüft werden wenn ich
ein positives ergebnis bei dem selbst
habe muss ich unbedingt noch einen
sicherungs test eine pcr machen
bis dahin sollte mich in quarantäne
verhalten und begeben
ab samstag sollen die selbsttests bei
aldi verfügbar sein
für 25 euro pro film verpackung also
fünf euro pro test ab mitte nächster
woche wollen weitere discounter
supermärkte und drogerien selbsttests
anbieten auch apotheken
dort könnte ein test das doppelte kosten
eine zweiklassengesellschaft befürchten
nun sozialverbände die menschen die in
dickeren geldbeutel haben können sich
tests kaufen und können dann mit dem
negativen testergebnis dann was
positives machen sprich an der
gesellschaft teilhaben die die sich das
nicht leisten können müssen weiterhin zu
hause bleiben mehr sicherheit die kostet
das gesundheitsministerium prüft derzeit
ob es die selbsttests bezuschusst soviel
zum thema corona auch die runde bei
maybrit illner diskutiert gleich nach
dem heute journal um viertel nach zehn
die korona beschlüsse wenn sie die noch
mal in ruhe nachlesen wollen in unserer
zdf heute app finden sie einen überblick
über die geplanten öffnungs schritte und
weitere massnahmen frieden in
afghanistan das war das ziel eines
abkommens zwischen den usa und den
radikal islamischen taliban
ein ziel das immer weiter in die ferne
rückt die neue us-regierung will den
eingeleiteten truppenabzug nun prüfen
deutschland wird sein einsatz wohl um
zehn monate verlängern
heute hat der bundestag beraten seit 20
jahren sind nato truppen vor ort doch
die lage ist schlecht taliban-kämpfer
kontrollieren weite teile des landes
immer wieder gibt es neuen terror und
neue opfer katrin eigendorf
es vergeht kein tag ohne gewalt seitdem
die usa begonnen haben ihre truppen
abzuziehen werden vor allem frauen immer
öfter zur zielscheibe richterinnen
politikerinnen und jetzt wieder drei
afghanische journalist innen die in
jalalabad auf offener straße erschossen
wurden
tarifa safari ist nur noch mit
bewaffnetem begleitschutz unterwegs die
autor wurde aus dem hinterhalt
beschossen sie hat nur knapp überlebt
als bürgermeisterin der provinzmetropole
mancher ist sie ein ziel für anschläge
jede fahrt ein risiko die 29 jährige
will sich nicht einschüchtern lassen
doch sie fürchtet um die zukunft dass
die usa vor einem jahr ein
friedensabkommen mit den taliban
geschlossen haben sieht sie kritisch die
gewalt habe enorm zugenommen vor allem
gezielte tötungen ich bin selbst eines
der opfer mein vater wurde wegen dieser
enormen zunahme von gewalt getötet
noch sind 10.000 ausländische
soldatinnen im land seit 2005 10
vor allem als militärischer berater
deutschland stellt mit 1100 soldatinnen
das zweitgrößte kontingent deutschland
hat 20 jahre hier verbracht ihre
soldaten sind hier getötet wurden
es wurde viel geld investiert all das
darf nicht umsonst gewesen sein
es steht viel auf dem spiel besonders
für die frauen dass die internationalen
truppen ihren abzug stoppen darauf setzt
jetzt die regierung in kabul
alle hoffnungen das oberlandesgericht
koblenz hat eine aes rückkehrerin wegen
mitgliedschaft in einer
terrororganisation zu zwei jahren haft
auf bewährung verurteilt die frau aus
rheinland pfalz hatte sich in syrien dem
s angeschlossen und war von 2014 bis
mitglied der termin ließ laut urteil
muss die 30-jährige die strafe nicht im
gefängnis verbüßen da sie die phase der
religiösen radikalisierung endgültig
hinter sich gelassen habe die
entscheidung ist noch nicht
rechtskräftig
die vereinten nationen haben das
gewaltsame vorgehen der militärs unter
gegen demonstranten scharf verurteilt
die so wörtlich brutale unterdrückung
der bevölkerung müsse beendet werden
trotz der eskalation protestierten in
einigen städten wieder menschen gegen
die militärregierung hunderte
begleiteten die beerdigung eines
erschossenen demonstranten beim bisher
blutigsten proteste gestern hatten
sicherheitskräfte mindestens 38 menschen
erschossen
mit flugreisen geld verdienen in der
pandemie mehr als schwierig und so
meldet die lufthansa heute den höchsten
verlust der firmengeschichte 2020 hat
die größte deutsche airline 6,7
milliarden euro minus gemacht 31.000
jobs wurden bereits abgebaut viele
flugzeuge stillgelegt die lufthansa war
im vergangenen jahr mit insgesamt neun
milliarden euro staatshilfen vor der
pleite gerettet worden
gleicher lohn für gleiche arbeit davon
ist nicht nur deutschland noch weit
entfernt
im schnitt verdienen frauen und 19
prozent weniger als männer
in sechs tagen am 10 märz ist der
sogenannte equal pay day das heißt bis
dahin arbeiten frauen sozusagen umsonst
im vergleich zu dem was männer im jahr
verdienen brüssel will dagegen jetzt
vorgehen auch mit mehr transparenz anne
gellinek berichtet frauen spüren die
krise als erste zerrissen zwischen home
office und kinderbetreuung ihre jobs in
service restaurants und handel sind
besonders gefährdet und immer noch
werden sie schlechter bezahlt die
lohnlücke in der europäischen union
verringert sich nur im schneckentempo
und liegt im eu durchschnitt bei 14,1
prozent heißt männer im gleichen job
verdienen 14 prozent mehr nur drei
länder
luxemburg rumänien und italien schaffen
ist die lücke auf unter fünf prozent zu
verkleinern
schlusslichter mit über 20 prozent
lohnunterschied sind estland und
österreich deutschland nicht viel besser
bei 19,2 prozent
gründe gibt es viele frauen unterbrechen
ihre karrieren öfter als männer weil sie
kinder bekommen und sie werden bei der
bezahlung diskriminiert die abwesenheit
von transparenz bei den gehältern macht
es schwer lohnunterschiede zu erkennen
zu geben und das problem zu lösen
deshalb schlägt die kommission vor dass
unternehmen mit mehr als 250
mitarbeitern einmal im jahr die gehälter
von männern und frauen im internet
veröffentlichen müssen
bei einer lücke von mehr als fünf
prozent sollen firmen und arbeitnehmer
wege suchen das zu verändern
frauen sollen die möglichkeit haben
schadensersatz zu fordern wenn
mitgliedstaaten und europaparlament
zustimmen würden dadurch die bereits
geltenden gesetze in deutschland
verschärft damit frauen künftig bei den
gehältern nicht mehr hinter den männern
zurück bleiben rückschritt als
fortschritt können dicht beieinander
liegen
der amerikanische raumfahrtkonzern
spacex arbeitet daran dass raketen
wieder landen können bei zwei
vorangegangenen versuchen waren sie
dabei explodiert diesmal glückte es
erstmals zunächst zumindest der
unbemannte prototyp kehrte nach dem
start in texas wieder in den stand
zurück acht minuten später dann doch die
explosion für firmen gründer elon musk
dennoch ein erfolg und jetzt zum sport
mit rudi ja und einem erfolgreichen
teenager der erst 19 jährige
österreicher johannes lampater ist
völlig überraschend weltmeister in der
nordischen kombination geworden
als bester deutscher erreichte rekord
weltmeister eric frenzel bei der heim-wm
in oberstdorf rang vier
erstmals seit 1999 stand im wettkampf
von der grossschanze kein deutscher auf
dem podium
hochfliegende gold träume enden um sanft
und abrupt schon nach dem springen sind
alle deutschen medaillenhoffnungen
verflogen vorgeführt vor allem von
johannes lampater aus österreich der ist
nach 138 metern landet wir haben leider
kleine fehler eingebaut und das ist
heute sehr bestraft worden
lampard gelingt ein ungefährdeter
zugleich überraschender wm-sieg vor dem
norweger riba und zwar aus japan den
deutschen bleibt nach toller
laufleistung nur das duell um platz vier
den frenzel vor riesler ruth sieger des
tages aber ein junger österreicher auch
die deutschen skilangläuferinnen haben
im wm staffelrennen von oberstdorf die
medaillen knapp verpasst beim souveränen
sieg der norwegerinnen kam das dsv
quartett auf der 4 x 5 kilometer strecke
aber immerhin auf einen respektablen
fünften platz
der letzte wechsel der staffel die
deutschen noch auf rang drei
die hoffnung auf eine medaille war da
doch das kleine wunder in bronze blieb
der staffel über die 4 x 5 kilometer
verwehrt schlussläuferin viktoria kahl
konnte der starken konkurrenz wenig
entgegensetzen
beim sieg der norwegerinnen um die jetzt
13 fache weltmeisterin therese johaug
landete das deutsche quartett himmler
helmut fink und karl habe auf einem
starken fünften platz
silber gewinnt die russische mannschaft
finnland bronze ja und im
dfb-pokal-viertelfinale unterstrich
leipzig gestern gegen wolfsburg seine
derzeit glänzende verfassung
allerdings profitierte rb auch von
diesem fehlschuss des wolfsburger
torjägers sich horst bei einem strafstoß
in der zweiten hälfte gelang den nun
druckvolleren leipzigern durch paulsen
der führungstreffer
den 2 0 endstand von nagelsmann steam
erzielte dann der südkoreanische joker
[Applaus]
das war zum ende der woche wird es
kälter in deutschland auch schneeflocken
rieseln vom himmel wo genau erklärt
gleich katja horneffer so viel von uns
im heute journal mit claus kleber einen
kommentar zu den corona beschlüssen von
chefredakteur peter frey
schön dass sie dabei waren ich hoffe wir
sehen uns morgen wieder bis dahin
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
während der saharastaub uns heute hier
ostwärts verließ kam ein kleines
tieferen das brachte 20 jahr fast 30
liter regen pro quadratmeter in kurzer
zeit hier im nördlichen nordrhein
westfalen und auch in nordhessen die
regenschauer die ziehen jetzt in der
nacht auch weiter nach süden und
oberhalb von etwa 400 meter wird in den
mittelgebirgen auch schnee daraus machen
sie sich also auf straßenglätte gefasst
im südwesten bleibt es beim regen denn
da sinken die temperaturen in der nacht
auf plus sechs bis plus drei grad
deutlich kälter über das richtung norden
mit minus 1 bis minus 6 grad
morgen dann kommt die kälte auch in
süddeutschland so erwarten uns
höchsttemperaturen zwischen null und
sieben grad und das wird ein sehr
sonniger märztag in norddeutschland beim
nördlichem witt im erzgebirge im
oberpfälzer und dem bayerischen wald
kann das morgen vormittag noch etwas
schneien südlich der donau bleibt es
grau und da geht der regen immer mehr in
schnee über es können so fünf bis zehn
zentimeter neuschnee zusammenkommen in
den östlichen mittelgebirgen aber auch
am alpenrand auch in der nacht auf
samstag schneit es noch dann aber wird
es häufig freuen sich und erst ab
sonntag drohen dann dichtere wolken in
norddeutschland schönen abend noch